hi everyone
this is professor m science and today i
want to prove
the heisenberg uncertainty principle in
another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics
the heisenberg uncertainty principle is
one of the most famous results in the
whole physics
the aim of this video is straightforward
we go over the mathematical proof
of the heisenberg uncertainty principle
so the emphasis today is on the maths
rather than the physics for a full
discussion of the physical implications
of the principle
there is a companion video that i
encourage you to check out let's go
let's start by stating the heisenberg
uncertainty principle
many of you will have encountered it
before state it as delta x
times delta p larger than or equal to
one half times h bar
in this expression delta x and delta p
are the root mean square deviations of
these two observables
and we typically call them the
uncertainty in x and the uncertainty in
p
using this language the expression tells
us that the product of these two
uncertainties has a non-zero low about
h bar over 2. it turns out that it is
just a special case of the uncertainty
principle
and in reality there is an uncertainty
principle for any pair of observables
a and b the most general form of the
uncertainty principle
says that the root mean square deviation
of observable a
multiplied by the root mean square
deviation of observable b
is larger than or equal to one half
times the absolute value of the
expectation value
of the commutator of a and b
the key quantities in the heisenberg
consistency principle are the delta a
and delta b
which are the root mean square
deviations of these two operators
remember that the root mean square
deviation delta a of an operator a for a
system in state psi
is equal to the square root of the
expectation value
of sigma a squared where sigma a
is equal to a minus the expectation
value of a
and remember also that we can write
delta a as equal to this
in today's video i'll assume that you
are familiar with these expressions
if you aren't then you should first
check the video on expectation values
which you can find linked in the
description
going back to the heisenberg concert in
the principle there is a companion video
in which we go over what the uncertainty
principle means
from a conceptual point of view what i
want to do in this video
is to show the mathematical proof of the
heisenberg uncertainty principle here
so if all you want is a conceptual
understanding of the principle
feel free to stop watching now and go to
the companion video
however if what you're looking for is to
learn where the uncertainty principle
comes from
then you should definitely join me
derivation and actually think it's quite
fun
to prove the heisenberg answer in the
principle we need a number of
intermediate results
and we start with the shards inequality
consider state chi given by the linear
superposition of state psi
and another state alpha phi
using the positivity property of the
scalar product we know that the bracket
of chi with itself
is larger than or equal to zero
plugging in the definition of chi we get
this
and multiplying through we get these
four terms
feel free to pause here for a second to
cross check this but it should be clear
after a moment
now this relation is true for any scalar
alpha so in particular it is true for
this choice of alpha
which you should commit yourself is just
a scalar plugging in this alpha we get
these new four terms
again feel free to pause here and
convince yourself of this step
moving on we recall that the conjugate
of a bracket simply exchanges the terms
and that as a consequence we can write
the absolute value squared of a bracket
like this
we can now write this whole expression
in this more compact form
with the first term here staying
unchanged
the second term here gives this
the third term here gives this
the fourth term here gives this
and then all of this is larger than or
equal to zero
this term now cancels with this term and
rearranging we get that side
psi times phi phi is larger than or
equal to the absolute value squared
of psi phi
this final result is what we call the
schwarz inequality and it actually
appears in many areas of mathematics
what we have here is the result in the
context of state vectors in state space
relevant for quantum mechanics
to make progress consider two
observables a
and b with the associated operators
sigma a
and sigma b
sigma a dagger is equal to a minus the
expectation value of
a all dagger which expanded gives this
as a is an observable it is hermitian so
this is equal to this
and in turn this gives sigma a implying
that for a hermitian then sigma a is
also her mission
we can of course say the same about
sigma b
also consider state psi for our system
next we define state psi a as equal to
sigma a
psi and state psi b as equal to sigma b
psi we can straight away use the schwarz
inequality for these two states
and we find that psi a psi a times psi b
psi b is larger than or equal to the
absolute value squared of psi a
psi b let's now explore what psi 8 psi
is using its definition up here we can
write it out like this
but sigma is hermitian so this is equal
to sigma u squared
we can therefore write psi 8 psi a as
equal to the expectation value
of sigma a squared with respect to the
state's psi of our system
or in shorthand like this
in a similar manner we can show that psi
b psi b is equal to the expectation
value
of sigma b squared with respect to the
state psi
and that psi a psi b is equal to the
expectation value
of sigma a sigma b with respect to the
state psi
we can now replace these expressions
into the schwarz inequality
and we get that the expectation value of
sigma a squared times the expectation
value of sigma b
squared is larger than or equal to the
absolute value squared of the
expectation value
of sigma a times sigma b
if we remember the heisenberg
uncertainty principle the right hand
side should eventually contain a
commutator
so to get a bit closer to that result we
will start by applying a useful operator
identity that is very easy to prove
consider two operators x and y
then if you take one half times the
commutator of the two operators
plus one half times the anticommutator
of the two operators
you can then expand them into these four
terms
feel free to pause here for a second to
double check this
but moving on these two terms cancel and
these two terms combine
so we get x y
so this here is a very useful result
that we can use in our derivation
if we apply the equality to sigma a and
sigma b instead of x and y
we get this
let's next consider the commutator of
sigma a and sigma b
explicitly it gives this can then use
the definition of the sigma operators
and we can then multiply through to get
these eight terms
now definitely stop here for a second to
cross check that you're happy with this
this cancels with this this with this
and this with this so we end up with a b
minus b a which is simply the commutator
of a and b
this means that we can write sigma a
sigma b as equal to one half times the
commutator of a
and b and then the anticommutator as
before
let's now think about the properties of
the two terms on the right hand side
let's start with the commutator if we
calculate its adjoint
we can expand the commutator
remembering that the adjoint of a
product changes the order of the terms
we get this
then a and b are hermitian so we get
this
which is the negative of the commutator
this means that the commutator is
anti-hermitian for a general
anti-hermitian operator
x consider the complex conjugate of the
expectation value
it is given by this
then we can use the conjugation property
of the scalar product
as x is anti-hermitian we get this
and this is minus the expectation value
of x
as the complex conjugate of the
expectation value of x is equal to minus
the expectation value of x
this implies that the expectation value
of an anti-hermitian operator x
is purely imaginary
if we now do the same for the
anticommutator
we can expand and then using the rule
for the adjoint of products and the fact
that the sigmas are hermitian
we straight away get this which is equal
to the anti-commutator
this means that the anticommutator is
her mission
for a general hermitian operator y we
again look at the complex conjugate
expanding we get this then we use
conjugation
then the fact that y is hermitian to get
this so it is equal to the expectation
value of y
this means that for hermitian operator
the expectation value is purely real
so overall for us this means that the
commutator of a and b is purely
imaginary
and the anticommutator of sigma and
sigma b is purely real
we're almost there we just found that
this term is purely imaginary
while this term is purely real this
means that the absolute value squared is
trivially the sum of the squares
of the two terms so we can write that
the expectation value
of sigma a squared multiplied by the
expectation value of sigma b
squared is larger than or equal to the
absolute value squared
of the commutator plus the absolute
value squared of the anticommutator
both terms on the right hand side are
positive or zero so we can drop the
anticommutator term
and this new equality is still true
taking the square root of both sides we
get this
and using the definition of the root
mean square deviation
this is simply delta a delta b is larger
than or equal
to one half times the absolute value of
the expectation value
of the commutator of a and b yay
that's it this is the heisenberg
uncertainty principle proofed
it relates the root mean square
deviations also called uncertainties
of two operators to their commutator
this result is valid for any general
pair of observables
a and b however you'll probably be more
familiar with a particular example of
this principle
that involves the operators of position
and momentum
in this case the commutator is equal to
i h bar
then we get delta x delta p greater than
or equal to
one half times the absolute value of i h
bar
which in turn gives delta x delta p
greater than or equal to
one half times h bar i really enjoy
playing with the maths so this sort of
proof is really fun for me
and i hope you also like to see where
the heisenberg uncertainty principle
comes from
and don't forget to check the companion
video to understand the full physical
implications of the principle and as
always
please subscribe